what we're going to do in this video is
get some practice estimating adding and
subtracting three digit numbers and so
here it says 398 plus 251
is and this squiggly equal sign means we
just need to make an estimate we want to
know what is this roughly equal to
so normally i say pause the video but
here i want you to work it out in your
head so i'm just going to pause i'm just
going to stop talking for like a second
and see if you can come up with what
this is or maybe i'll give you
three seconds because the whole point
here is to estimate not get the exact
right answer
okay so i'm assuming you've had a go at
it now i'll tell you how i think about
it we of course could maybe take out
some paper or you might even be able to
get the exact answer in your head but in
everyday life if you're at the
supermarket and you're like okay i guess
would be an expensive supermarket
something is 398 dollars something else
is 251
roughly how much would i be spending if
i bought both of them well my head would
say all right 398 i would round to
nearest 10 at least maybe the nearest
hundred so let's round to the nearest
10. and in the case of 398 the nearest
10 is the nearest hundred and so we
would get two this is approximately 400
and then this is 251 is approximately
250.
so if you were to add these two things
up you're going to get something that is
approximately equal to
650 and lucky for us that is one of the
choices
and what i'm about to do is not estimate
but just see how far off we were so if
we were to just actually do it 398
plus
eight plus one is nine
nine plus five is fourteen this is
fourteen tens we put four tens here and
the other ten tens we regroup as a
hundred and then one plus three plus two
hundred is 600 so in this case in this
particular case we got awfully close
with our estimation and if you don't
need to get the exact number well
that'll that'll be fine
let's do another example and here we are
going to do a little bit of subtraction
so once again pause this video or try to
do it as quickly as you can try to
estimate what this difference is going
to be 678 minus 273.
all right let's do it together so
there's a couple of ways to tackle it
you could round to the nearest 10 and
you could say well this is approximately
600 let's see if you round to the
nearest 10 you would round up right over
here so you'd say this is 680
minus you could say
which is going to give you and here
you're still going to have to do some
mental math this would be what 600 minus
200 is 400 and 80 minus 70 is 10. so
that's one way to do it or you could do
it even rougher you could just do to the
nearest hundred so you could say look
678 the nearest hundred is 700 and then
minus 273 the nearest hundred there is
300 and so this is even rougher but it
gets us actually still similar answers
and either way we estimated either the
kind of rougher way or the slightly less
rough way we got to something around 400
so you could feel good that this is your
choice the reason why we even have to
make multiple choice questions for
estimation is not everyone is going to
get the exact same estimate but the
correct choice should be the one that a
re that any reasonable estimate would be
closest to